in a recent survey a majority of
respondents picked their sense of smell
as the one they'd be most willing to
give up among the traditional five
senses but if you love food you should
be giving your nose much more credit
because it's actually our sense of smell
that plays a huge role in our ability to
process flavor
[Music]
first let's talk about how smell works
from coffee to stinky trash the
substances around us give off volatiles
which you can think of as Tiny smell
molecules we breathe in these smell
molecules which then stimulate the
olfactory Sensory neurons that sit high
in the nose each of these neurons
contains an odor receptor on its surface
once the odor receptors are triggered by
these smell molecules the neurons send
information about them to the brain
here's what I think is so cool the brain
not only categorizes that information as
a particular odor it may also begin to
associate feelings like pleasure or
disgust and other moods and emotions
with that odor for future reference for
example you sniff bacon you eat it your
taste buds get salt and then your body
gets a lack of fat which is an energy
source so the brain loves it and a
matches a positive label to it the next
time you smell bacon a sensation
associated with pleasure arises now
there are a lot of smells out there more
than our 400 or so odor receptors can
detect but people with a healthy working
sense of smell have odor receptors that
can combine to detect anywhere between
ten thousand to more than a trillion
different odors now taste is completely
different it comes from taste receptors
on our tongues and in our mouths taste
is limited to the basics salty Sweet
Bitter sour and somewhat controversially
Umami or savory you can taste without
smell but anyone with a stuffy nose can
attest that's a pretty bland experience
that's because when we eat for example
chewing Pizza the pizza releases
volatiles that travel from our mouths
and throat up through the nasal passage
there will Factory neurons get all the
complex smells from the pizza and send
that information to the brain smell and
taste work together to help us enjoy
food when our nose isn't working
properly and food seems flavorless it's
because we're only tasting those basic
tastes without any of the complex odors
detected through smell so the next time
you Savor an amazing flavor thank your
nose our sense of smell is what brings
Nuance to what we eat